let's go back to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 let's go to our caller from the
4-1 7 area code who's been holding on
thank you for calling who's this and
what's on your mind today hi this is
that be on and Joplin Missouri
go ahead ed what's going on I was kind
of piggybacking off that last caller I
was more curious about the possibility
they're very realistic possibility of it
the 2020 election doesn't happen because
all incentives for this administration
seems to be obscure face up obfuscate
and and lie and and just challenge
reality yeah so what what is their
motivation to actually just if the
Muller investigation comes through with
whatever the caller previous caller
thought yeah to accept it like I don't
understand what anyone thinks will
actually force this administration to
follow the rule of law well listen they
would have to really take drastic
measures to suspend the twenty20
election now let's step back for a
second when President Obama was
president you had a ton of people on the
right saying Obama is about to declare
martial law and or suspend the election
and declare himself king or whatever
right but the idea was he's going to
just figure out a way to get another
term or to become president indefinitely
and of course there was zero indication
that it was even something that remotely
occurred to President Obama because it
would be idiocy to even think that
that's something he would do Trump has
actually said that what the Chinese
President did to change the law to allow
himself to just be reelected
indefinitely
is something that's kind of cool and
maybe he would want to look into in the
future so even though Trump has actually
said he kind of likes the idea of being
possibly president for life it's just I
just don't think it's really productive
to be talking about that the the idea
that Trump would be able to do it
I find extraordinarily hard to believe
even Republicans that are in the tank
forum if they retain power in the House
and Senate I just don't understand how
that will be allowed to have
and although I'm scared that I could be
wrong because of the creeping
authoritarianism I it could get so bad
in the next two years that it occurs to
someone like hey maybe this is the time
to make it so you can serve another term
but I I don't think IDI that it's the
logical thing to be thinking about like
his Trump gonna suspend the 2020
election well III wouldn't have believed
that a year and a half ago but you know
when we found out that children were
being locked in prison and yeah
kidnapped from their their parents I
would have thought that would have
caused a major outrage but really that's
not even a news story anymore yeah I
know it's as we go forward the the heat
on the Frog continues to to to raise I
maybe it's my naivete but I don't think
there's really a risk of Trump
suspending the twenty20 election and I
hope sometimes I say I hope I'm wrong I
hope I'm not wrong yet I really really
appreciate the phone call